- Oh, God.
This is gonna get so weird.
(rock music)
- So, we are doing the sexy challenge.
Taking store-bought, not-so-sexy costumes,
and making them sexy.
- Is there any costume
that you can't make sexy?
Donald Trump?
Other than that, though,
I think most everything can be made sexy.
- Literally anything is fair game.
- I believe that any
costume can be made sexy.
What level of sexiness this is
or what fetish it really
covers, it depends.
(drumming)
- Oh my gosh.
- Yes.
- What?
(laughing)
- Oh, God.
- The costume I got is a wizard sorcerer.
- I have been given the
beekeeper's costume.
- Everything that is
required to be a clown.
- Rockin' rooster, funky chicken.
Love, love, love.
- I think this is going to be pretty easy,
there's, like, a lot of fabric.
I get to choose what part of it's sexy,
'cause it's kind of like a blank canvas.
- The sexy clown is nightmare-fuel.
And this is going to be fucking insane.
- I want it to be like a,
like a goth, dominatrix chicken.
- This is real fashion.
- So I think you got to lose
the fingers to the gloves.
So it's like a fingerless,
sexy clown-glove.
- I'm gonna cut me a little split.
Keepin' it sexy.
- Taking off the sleeves,
the sleeves have got to go.
Any sexy outfit doesn't have sleeves.
You know that.
We all know that.
- What if I, like, didn't
wear a shirt underneath
and, like, just cut out the nipples?
- I'm just gonna, like, Regina
George this to start with.
- I don't know if sexy is the right word,
but it's really swinging for it.
- Oh, proving hard.
(whimsical music)
I'm a visionary.
- Maybe I'll make some, like,
mysterious peepholes in it, too, to match.
- Like assless chaps?
(laughs)
- What the hell we are
gonna do with this wig?
- I think you got to
go creepy clown mohawk.
- Jeez, Louise.
- I mean, this is pretty hot.
- Another thing I can't stress enough,
don't do this at home.
- Also like masks are
kind of sexy in general.
Yeah, I mean, that's pretty good.
(funky music)
- [Hal] I think that if
you put your mind to it,
you can make any costume sexy.
- [Kenah] I think, like,
if I was to do it again,
I would tie these guys on like
I tied the bee to my head.
Maybe they can come off during the party
and that's part of it.
It's kind of more like
I've been attacked by bees,
more than sexy for the bees.
- I think (laughs)
I look like a psycho!
Big fan of the...
nipple gaps.
- I don't.
But I kinda do.
I was doubting myself before
and I'm pretty confident.
I think we all did a really good job.
- If you can make this cross
section of costume sexy,
then I think the sky's the limit.
- If you want to be sexy,
if you want to be funny,
if you want to be silly,
if you want to be,
like, stylish, do what you want.
- Do you.
- I know it, you know it,
I'm a very sexy chicken.
(funky music)
- [Kenah] Verifying element,
so we could all walk
up to a place together,
and be like, "Someone
robbed a costume store."